today on the Matt wall show desperate
Democrats are warning that voting
Republican means the death of democracy
but the real threat to our democracy and
in fact our whole civilization comes
from somewhere else it comes in part
from the protesters of my event last
night who are ripping Pages out of the
Bible and eating them I'll explain also
Ted Cruz bravely walks into the chicken
coop and debates the squawking hens of
the view CNN tries to embarrass Trump
voters in a focus group but it doesn't
work out the way they intended Sandy
Hook families now want to sue Alex Jones
for trillions of dollars with a t
trillions and one of the most prominent
Native American activists in the country
who just died recently wasn't actually
native American at all imagine that all
of that and more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
the left is losing their faith but we
are not and a core part of that faith is
prayer I talk a lot about stressful
things all day and you might feel a
little overwhelmed with uh where the
country is going but I've got good news
hallow can help you find some peace and
hope rooted not in the government or its
institutions but in God hallow has over
5 000 audio guided prayers meditations
and peaceful Christian music including
the rosary with Mark with Bishop Baron
and Mark Wahlberg the Bible in a year
with father Mike Schmitz prayers for
kids so we aren't raising another
generation of crazies and many more
hallow helps you build a daily routine
and a habit of prayer it helps me to
pray meditate and sleep better it's a
huge part of my daily routine you get
exclusive three-month trial of hallo
hallow.com Matt Walsh that's hallow.com
Matt Walsh reclaim your piece in this
crazy world download hello today
we are now officially uh two weeks from
election day there was some question
over the summer about whether it would
really materialize but now it seems
rather clear that the red tsunami is
coming uh we can see the signs the water
level dropping the tide going out the
wave gathering strength as it heads to
Shore and when I talk about signs I
don't mean the polls which are all fake
and made up and meaningless and who
cares I'm talking about the Democrats
themselves how they're behaving
what they're saying they know what's on
the horizon and that's why they're
becoming so desperate and frantic so
this weekend we saw Joe Biden promising
a bunch of tick-tock stars that he would
pay for their abortions and make sure
that every state in the Union is
sexually mutilating children this is
what democratic desperation looks like
this is what they do when they're scared
they double down on their infanticide
and child castration advocacy also even
more indicative the Democrats are
warning that the coming Republican
takeover of the house and possibly the
Senate as well will will spell the end
of Democracy in America so max boot
writes for the Washington Post quote if
the current trends hold up Republicans
are likely to take over at least the
house and quite possibly the Senate too
along with many State offices
this is how democracies die both at home
and abroad
so democracies die
when voters participate in them says the
Washington Post so by voting you are
killing democracy in a similar way uh
you might die of thirst by drinking
fresh water or drown by sitting on dry
land
MSNBC had a similar message last night
in fact they took it a step further
according to Joy Reid and her panel of
guests who all together with their brain
power combined equal the IQ of a
moderately intelligent meerkat if voters
they say vote for republicans
they are essentially Nazis listen
Matthew we talk about this all the time
democracy on the ballot it's not just a
slogan you know I mean we're talking
about women literally losing agency over
themselves Donald Trump has said you
know where he's going to challenge the
election already in advance he says he's
going to do it Philly
dog whistle right I mean it's not even
being hidden at this point it's just
fascism in the open and what scares me
is that I'm not sure everybody Minds you
know I think there are some people who
will just sit back and let it happen
thinking it won't be that bad and that
to me is almost more dangerous than the
radicals
well I mean I'm not calling I'm not
going to say that you know the GOP or
Nazis at this point or whatever but it
certainly sounds very familiar to what
happened in Germany which is a bunch of
citizens Davidoff Hitler gets a third of
the vote nobody thought it could happen
there they kind of went along because
they said he was going to solve the
economy and fix inflation yeah that's
right because you can hear those sorts
of things and then oh but lo and behold
a few years later they lost their
democracy and they're all like how'd
that happen here that's my worry that is
my worry if obviously the price of a
hamburger the price of milk the the
price of gas is concerning but what is
what does that is a short-term problem
the loss of a democracy will decimate
everyone's freedom
yes your inability to eat is a
short-term problem I mean
I guess it probably is the only problem
is that they're you know you might not
have an opportunity for any problems
after that if you're not able to eat uh
but I I am I have to say I'm I am
begging all of you absolutely begging
you especially on the left to learn
about something in history other than
the Nazis not that you actually know
anything about the Nazis or how they
Rose to power of course your
understanding of your one single
historical period of interest is dubious
at best but but it's really time to
Branch out anyway it really is other
things have happened in the world before
and since I promise you there are other
things that you could compare current
events to the possibilities for
historical analogies are endless but you
have to read a history book first
then event I do appreciate Matthew
dowd's prudence and restraints I'll give
him credit for that because he says that
he's not going to compare the GOP to
Nazis but all he's saying is that
the GOP are just like the Nazis
he's not going to make the comparison
he's simply pointing out that
Republicans are exactly like the Nazis
that's all and you are ushering in the
end of democracy if you vote for them
this is all Preposterous of course
democracy is not under threat because of
Republicans
but that is not to say that democracy
isn't under threat at all I mean it is
and it's much more than democracy that
hangs in the balance the entirety of
Western Civilization is on the brink of
collapse is indeed in the process of
collapsing
it's not because of one election or one
political events
it's because we are as a society
rejecting
fundamental basic truth our
civilizational flight from truth is the
real threat
to democracy to civilization you can't
have a functioning democracy without
truth you can't have a thriving country
or any real country at all without you
can only have chaos and misery
which brings me to my event last night
at the University of Wisconsin-Madison
um yesterday I told you about the drama
and the lead up to the screening of of
my film and my speech and Q a afterwards
left to students and faculty were losing
their minds over the prospect of my
physical presence on campus they filed a
bias incident report they tore down
Flyers they set up safe spaces they
graffitied all over the campus including
vandalizing a Veterans Memorial
when I finally arrived on campus
yesterday over 300 protesters apparently
was the number gathered outside many
tried to rush inside the building some
made it in some were stopped they rushed
into the screening of the film they
tried to disrupt it I'm told that one of
the protesters literally vomited like
out of Rage an actual scene from The
Exorcist played out during my talk they
repeatedly pulled the fire alarm
which had the effect of knocking the AV
system out so I didn't have a working
microphone for a large portion of the
speech fortunately I have a loud enough
voice so that was only a minor
inconvenience back outside they ranted
and raved and coherently often branched
often branching into grievances that
have seemingly nothing to do with the
subject of my film or my talk here's
just one example listen
and that includes an
accommodated by white people who don't
give bipart voices a chance
but white people you need to realize
your positionality you need to realize
the space you take up I need to realize
how hard it is
just
that voice is hard to listen to uh yes
people of color are not able to speak
she screams
into a megaphone
most of the speeches and chants were
targeting me and explaining why I'm a
horrible person the interesting thing
about this girl is that she was at least
partially targeting her own comrades
it doesn't take long for them to start
to eat each other
and eat other things too actually as the
protest grew it also became more
explicitly satanic there was one woman
who pulled out a Bible and began ripping
Pages out of it and eating them and we
could see that see her do that here if
you thought I was exaggerating when I
call these people demonic well here you
go
um I spoke yesterday about the helpful
contrast right that you see with these
when these leftist protesters show up
here's another one
which way
will you go America that's the choice
you have Which Way Western man do you
want to join in with the side that eats
the Bible and vomits and anger
kills babies castrates little children
or do you want to join literally any
side but that one I mean this is the
choice to be made
sadly though up to this point
our civilization has made its choice
and it shows the Bible eaters it shows
the screaming [ __ ] lunatics
fundamentally it shows untruth
because as I am constantly reminding
everyone this this is what these people
represent it's what they advocate for
it's what they
demand it's why they protest
it's not merely about silencing
conservative voices it's not about
squashing debate or discussion it is all
of that
but more importantly it's about driving
truth even the most basic truths
especially the most basic truths out of
college campuses out of all of our
institutions out of the Public Square
off of social media off of all the
platforms and often to Exile
their goal is to build a society apart
from truth where they can make their own
their own truth and live in their
relativistic Utopia one in which
everything revolves around the self and
around the ego
but we've seen how this Utopia works
specifically we've seen that it doesn't
it doesn't work
a civilization grounded in relativism is
not grounded at all it is weak and
unstable it will collapse and it will
take everything down with it including
democracy
that's what's at stake here
and that's why we may be tempted to
laugh at these embarrassing displays on
college campuses I laugh at them but
what lies underneath all of the hysteria
is this war on Truth these kids have
been conditioned to lash out blindly
violently with rage and fury
at any discussion of truth that any
individual who speaks truth
that's why I'm doing all this why I'm in
the fight I I see
this as a fight for truth itself and
thus for civilization itself
to reiterate what I said at the end of
my speech last night if you'll forgive
me plagiarizing myself
um it really is as simple as this for me
that the truth matters and it matters
more than anything else
it matters more than ideology it matters
more than your preferences your feelings
it matters more than your
self-identification
it matters more than your life and more
than mine see these leftist protesters
they claim that that my speaking truth
or anyone else who speaks truth that
when we do that we somehow put their
lives at risk now I don't think that's
true
they were not putting their lives at
risk by speaking the truth but even if
it was I would still speak it and I
would still encourage you to speak it
the truth would be worth the cost
you're worth the cost of their lives
it's worth the cost of my own life
I would speak the truth if it put my own
life at risk and according to the death
threats that I get all the time it does
and that's because life itself
can't have any meaning
nothing can have meaning
apart from the truth there's nothing to
fight for except the truth nothing to
live for except the truth there is no
love without it there's no Beauty
there's no joy there's no freedom
there's nothing without truth
and that's why we can't give it up
for anyone's sake
no matter what
now let's get to our five headlines
uh well there's one other clip I wanted
to play from last night before we move
on and I wish I could play the whole
exchange but it's it's too long I have a
kind of a longer clip that I'm going to
play it still but you can find the whole
clip of my what my Twitter page it's a a
during the Q a a person who identifies
as trans
I was going through transition right now
did come up to speak in the Q a and this
is doesn't happen very often this is
pretty rare I mean I do these q and A's
and anyone can come speak and I'm always
encouraging people don't agree with me
to come speak and very rarely do they
take me up on it they'd rather go uh
stay outside where they have their
numbers and they can shout into
megaphones and hold their signs and all
of that this was someone who actually
came and spoke and stood up there and uh
and I appreciate that it takes courage
it takes guts to do that
um from from you know from from his
perspective this is like walking into
the lion's den this is behind enemy's
territory from his we're not his enemies
but that's how he would see it and so it
takes guts to do this so I thought this
was an important conversation I wanted
to share
um
a piece of it with you here it is
eight months ago I was diagnosed with
gender dysphoria while I was impatient
here in UW-Madison
um
I looked into the research and like
talked to doctors and through my uh
journey I decided to explore medically
transitioning
you know because it's shown to decrease
suicidal ideation stuff like that
um
and since then although I've had to deal
with other issues such as transphobia
and sexual assault I've been more
happier overall than I ever was before
and my question to you is what
specifically about medically
transitioning do you think is so immoral
that we should ignore the potential
benefits and why should I listen to you
as somebody who's not a medical
professional and has not experienced
gender dysphoria there's a dishonesty
behind it dishonesty in the false
promises that they make
which is that you can attain this image
of
maleness or femaleness
but that you can actually become in some
ways the the opposite gender or sex
whatever words you want to use
which is a lie it's not true
you never can and I I have a horrible
Adam's Apple my my voice sounds like
this I still love myself and there is
only money in making people happy like
wearing nice clothes or good food it
does cost a lot of money that's why I
can't get surgeries that would make me a
lot happier
um
but the point of medicine is not
supposed to be to make you happy in the
moment that's not that's not the
objective of medicine the objective of
medicine is your overall wellness it's
about treating what is actually wrong
that's that's medicine and so if you are
struggling to
accept
who who you were born as what your
actual biological identity is I have all
the compassion in the world for that I
mean I can't imagine having that
disconnect in my head it has to be a
source of immense despair
but what I hate is the is the medical
professionals who instead of helping you
with that and how instead of helping you
to accept who you really are and find
joy and fulfillment in it
they're trying to make a quick buck and
they're selling you false promises and
they're telling you this stuff is based
on long-term studies and they're lying
to you because it's not there have never
been any reliable long-term studies on
almost all of this stuff because the
fact is the medical industry only
started doing this at such a large scale
recently so they couldn't have the data
they're pretending that they do they're
lying and that's what I hate
that's that's the immorality
okay so like I said that was a piece of
that's kind of the beginning and the end
and then there's the middle two which
you can find on my uh you can find on
YouTube where you find it on Twitter
um and I wanted to show that to you
because first of all again I just I
appreciate the fact that somebody was
actually willing to go and stand up
there and ask a question
um
and and also
I want to show that it's it's you know
we have this idea
that when you're talking to someone who
actually is trans or actually identifies
that way and is going through the whole
process that it's like we have to choose
between
being compassionate
or being truthful
those are two
separate paths those are two different
choices that's the way it's presented
that's not the case I think you can be
compassionate and also
um say what is true
which is what I tried to do there now if
I have one regret
and this is not meant as a criticism of
the audience who are great and really
all the audiences we've had on this
store have been have been awesome very
supportive and I appreciate them all
very much but I regret in some ways the
Applause for me at the end there not
that it was inappropriate it's just you
know it's the audience's way of saying
they agree and um and it was not it's
not like a combative Applause but it's
uh it's the nature of the Forum that's
how it works in that kind of form that's
fine but it does you know kind of makes
it sound maybe at the end like uh Matt
Walsh destroys type of video and that's
not what it is it's not what I intended
I certainly hope that the the student
you know didn't that that wasn't his
takeaway
um it's not this is not a matter of
trying to debunk or embarrass someone
certainly
um I care about him I do um I I care
about these kids who are being taken
advantage of
I know a lot of them
hate my guts they think that I'm a
horrible person I'm a monster and I get
that
that's how the way they see it that's
okay
but I care about them
that's
that's why I care about the issue
because people like that
who are
dealing with something dealing with
something real but it's internal it's
like something in his mind something
real
and if I had a chance to follow up with
that student I would tell them
first of all that you know it's it's
gonna be okay I know I know he's
suffering I don't doubt that
I know it
uh but it's going to be okay he is okay
there's nothing wrong with him
physically he says there that he uh he
talks about he hates his Adam's apple
and his voice but
there's nothing wrong with any of that
you know that's that's that's him that's
who he is
and there is nothing wrong with that at
all
that's who you are there's nothing wrong
with who you are
the the trouble is is when your mind is
not able to
reconcile with who you are or for
whatever reason is not wanting to accept
who you are
and so it's that struggle to accept that
that is the fundamental issue that we
need to try to address
as I'm always saying it is very much on
our side which is the side of uh of
Truth
is very much a message of actual
self-acceptance
of real affirmation
all right
I want to play this clip for you that
because there's there's so much that is
contained in this clip so much is uh is
shown is learned perhaps in this CNN
held a focus group with Trump supporters
in Pennsylvania
and the goal obviously because it's a
focus group with Trump supporters and
it's on CNN the goal is to embarrass
them and to show that they're a bunch of
ignoramuses
but it didn't work out that way in fact
it kind of worked exactly the opposite
way the person who's trying to embarrass
the Trump supporters only got
embarrassed in the process so I want to
go through and watch a little bit of
this let's see
Doug mastriano was at the Insurrection
and he was photographed breaching one of
the restricted areas
is that okay which area because I saw a
video where Capital officers were taking
away barriers and unlocking doors so I
mean I they opened the gate so it
shouldn't be disqualifying for an
elected official if they participated in
January 6th he didn't strike anybody he
didn't hurt anybody and the only one
that died was a protester there not a
capital police unarmed female veteran
that's the only one that died that's the
only one who died a police officer did
die no but that was a stroke that's not
that's not on site because he shouldn't
have been a police officer so what do
you make though overall of January 6th I
mean it was watching that footage it was
pretty disturbing I mean there were
people throwing extra minutes
so
uh she makes she pivots there it's like
well what do you make of January 6th in
general because
because she realized that what she is
telling what the claims that she's
making about January 6th are incorrect
and these people know that it's
incorrect so what's happening here is
that she's trying to Showcase their
ignorance
but instead uh in fact they are
educating her about January 6th they are
they are better educated on January 6
than she is
and she says this is a common
bit of misinformation that we still hear
somehow is that the police officers who
died on January 6 didn't happen
did not happen
um
there were no police officers killed
by the by the rioters on January 6. that
did not happen there's Brian sicknick
who had a stroke at a medical you know
had a medical emergency after the fact
and then there were there were there
were other police officers who in the
weeks and months afterwards there were I
think it was two who tragically
committed suicide and shamelessly
for you know years now it is the the the
left has been uh has been taking those
suicides
and connecting it to January without any
evidence whatsoever
so these people know all of that
because well how do they know it because
they although they're participating in a
CNN uh Forum or CNN you know focus group
they don't they don't rely on CNN to get
their information
really the sense rather than being a
Showcase of the ignorance of trump
voters which is what CNN was hoping for
it is a Showcase of of among other
things CNN's own irrelevance
that these random voters that they
picked up in uh Pittsburgh they don't
they don't they're not looking at CNN
for they don't care what CNN says
uh CNN has made itself irrelevant
so then she pivots to talk about January
6 in general let's keep watching this a
little bit
there are people throwing extra men at
the walls and it was our you know the
capital it looked a lot like antifa's
actually except on a much smaller scale
it looked the same as the black lives
matter right that's what I saw the
similarities
One Burns Kenosha but so it's okay just
because just because one side that you
disagree with
anybody who caused property destruction
that needs to be dealt with but if
you're there making your voice heard at
the people's house no less yeah that's
again it's a fundamental constitutional
right of an American citizen and people
should not be being held political
prisoner uh because of it for
misdemeanors that's East Germany that's
Easter tactics yeah that's what's scary
it was an actual fiery but mostly
peaceful protest
and the other ones that the world was
the protest
legitimate in your eyes I feel like is
using it as their rice dog fire yeah
that's exactly what they're using it as
do you think that President Trump could
have coiled the violence that day
not him I don't think so no I don't
think so it started while he was still
speaking I was actually there I was
there
I'd love to see an hour-long focus group
but this with this uh this group of
Americans here these Patriots and a CNN
anchor you know what I actually want to
see though
what I would love to see is a group of
democrat voters focus group ask the same
questions okay but get some democrat
voters get some leftists into a focus
group and start talking to them about
January 6th
and I guarantee uh there's gonna be a
whole lot more misinformation being
spread you know because because these
are people who actually rely on the
corporate media for their information
and uh if we were to swap them out for
leftists we're going to hear all about
how there was like a dozen police
officers with a bloodbath people lying
Dead all over the place
that's what we would hear
of course all the points that they make
about uh about compare you know what
happened with BLM riots and antifa all
totally valid
and CNN
reporter has no response to that other
than to say well just just because one
person so two wrongs don't make a right
are you admitting that it wasn't wrong
now because that would be something new
for CNN
are you admitting that the BLM rides
were actually wrong I don't think seeing
anyone at CNN has ever even admitted
that
as opposed to on the right right with
like this this one single example that
you have of people on the right rioting
that's what it was it was riot and these
were mostly people who are on the right
and it's happened one time in like
decades
okay as opposed to on the left when it's
I mean we went through a seat we went
through a period of a we went through a
season what was happening on a daily
basis
um but
you got your one example
and every conservative that I've ever
talked to we have no problem saying that
wasn't that shouldn't have happened that
was incredibly
stupid that's it's a horrible decision
okay there was I was saying it at the
time there's there's
nothing good can come of this for the
people who are participating in it
there's there's no good that comes of
this
at none whatsoever
now there's there's in fact there's good
for the left and for the the uh for the
elites and the powerful people in
Washington they're going to make hay of
this and that's exactly what they've
done in the um
in the in the many months after
following
so we have no problem saying that it's
no problem for us
on the left though they can't
they still have not gotten around
actually denouncing or admitting that uh
that any the the BLM did anything wrong
by writing
those many dozens and hundreds of times
that they did
all right similar theme Here Ted Cruz
um
was able to get himself onto the view
which I I have to admit to some I'm a
little bit a little bit sour about this
I'm a little uh I'm a little jealous
because this is my this is my dream this
is my dream is to be on The View Ted
Cruz was had a chance to be on there and
I I will say that if it can't be me you
know
um there is a there's
there are there's a selection of people
on the right who if it can't be me I
would love for it to be one of them I
think Ted Cruz is on that list because
he he handled this wonderfully and uh
there were a lot of Great Moments
um but I thought this about election
denial was maybe the best moment of all
listen
anytime a republican is in front of a TV
Camera try to say the election was fair
and square and legitimate you know who
y'all don't do that to you don't do it
to Hillary Clinton who stood up and said
Trump stole the elections
who said who said that the election was
stolen they sat here and said it was
illegitimate and you guys were fine with
it okay so it's illegitimate Republicans
no you know here's the thing we may not
like when Republicans win but we don't
go and we don't storm we don't try to
change
[Applause]
did I miss an entire year of antifa
riots where cities
your position is the left doesn't engage
in violence really no they wanted to
know our friend Mike Pence
accused us of doing something we didn't
do you said Hillary Clinton didn't say
whatever she didn't say I'm saying to
you listen
okay
all right she sat there while while
Donald Trump is an illegitimate
president Hillary Clinton says the
election is stolen from you Hillary
Clinton in 2002 George W Bush was
selected Not Elected Joe Biden Al Gore
was was elected president so Joe Biden
yeah
each other right or is it just you that
gets the screen
uh this is good and and we gotta give
credit to Ted Cruz because I know you
might think well that's easy to win an
argument with
I just said before the MSNBC panel had
the collective IQ of a meerkat but these
these women and there's more of them I
don't even think would make it uh would
make it that that high up on the scale
so you might think well see there's a
bunch of morons of course you could win
an argument and they are a bunch of
morons but but even so you it's it's
hard to to overstate
um how it kind of overwhelming it can be
to be in a totally hostile environment
even when you're surrounded by morons in
fact like especially if you're
surrounded by by morons in some ways and
uh everyone is you're sit at a table
everyone's against you the entire
audience is against you and to be able
to handle that uh is not something that
everyone can do I thought Ted Cruz did a
great job there
um and once again the point that he's
raising is obviously 100 correct
and but the answer from
the left and what you actually hear from
the women on The View there is well it's
different when we do it
and that's that's how they see it it's
different when we do it
so that's that's
always reminding you that's the standard
it's not so much a double standard there
is one standard uh which is that we can
do these things and you can't that's
what the standard is
which doesn't mean that we should Tire
of pointing out that fact
any any chance you get to point it out
and put it on display
for everyone else that's that's good
so Ted Cruz on The View he's this debate
is not about convincing
the women on The View they cannot be
convinced we all know that
um it's more for anyone else who might
see it any other spectator
all right a few days ago Marco Rubio
reported that a man who was canvassing
for him wearing a Rubio shirt into
Santa's hat was brutally assaulted by
someone because of his political views
Rubio tweeted quote last night one of
our canvassers wearing my t-shirt and a
DeSantis hat was brutally attacked by
four animals who told him Republicans
weren't allowed in their neighborhood
he suffered internal bleeding and a
broken jaw and will need facial
reconstructive surgery
so this is yeah this is apparently yet
another example of a conservative being
assaulted for his political views
something that is happening with
increasing regularity but the media
isn't interested in that story obviously
they don't want to talk about it so they
set out to find ways to either they
ignore it these stories or they find
ways to explain it away or outright
justify
the violence being committed against
conservatives and that's what they're
doing here as well Alex DeLuca with the
Miami New Times
tweets quote
the man attacked last night while
canvassing for Marco Rubio has been id'd
as Christopher monzone ex-member of the
white supremacist group league of the
South
despite Rubio's tweet about the incident
the police report does not mention a
political dispute nor does it indicate
that monzone was targeted because he's a
Republican
oh yes we know that uh
this white supremacists are famous for
their affinity for Marco Rubio you know
the white supremacists just love Marco
Rubio he's their favorite
now as for the alleged so we have two
issues here we have the justification
that is being offered for assaulting
this man
um and then also the claim that well
they're trying to set this up like it's
almost like it's a Jesse Smollett thing
and Marco Rubio made it up well as for
the alleged contradiction between the
police report and Rubio's claim here's
what the article says this is their
article
it says quote a police report supplied
to New Times indicates that Lopez that
Lopez
who's the guy who committed the assault
confronted monzone on East 60th Street
while monzone was handing out flyers
Lopez allegedly said you can't pass by
here this is my neighborhood during an
argument that followed Lopez grabbed
monzone and proceeded to slam him
against the ground according to the
report whereupon he continued beating
the defenseless monzone in the face
okay
that actually matches up pretty well
with what Rubio said this is not a
Justice Millet situation the assault
happened
and the circumstances around the assault
are similar in both accounts neither
contradicts the other
there are details missing which is
usually the case in the days immediately
following a violent crime so we'll find
out more as they investigate
but in fact based on the police report
this you know helps to confirm what
Marco Rubio said
um
as to the supposed white supremacist
connection
this is what it has come to right
digging up dirt on assault victims to
justify the assault
and that is why they're doing it
I don't know if it's true or not I don't
know anything about this guy's
background or what groups he's been
affiliated with I don't I'm not going to
believe anything just because the media
says it so I don't accept it as true but
it's also completely irrelevant
there's just no reason to be talking
about it
it's got nothing to do with anything
so why are they bringing it up
well they're bringing it up to again
justify the assault
uh
and justifying it it's it's not as
though the person who committed the
assault
knew that the person that he was
assaulting was allegedly affiliated with
the white supremacist group or whatever
it's more the media saying well this
guy's a white supremacist
uh so it doesn't really matter if he
gets beat up whatever the reason was
doesn't matter his life this is life
doesn't matter
that's why the left has spent so much
time
labeling all of us white supremacists
and Nazis
right we're all white supremacists and
Nazis if we disagree with them
and it doesn't matter our own ethnic it
doesn't matter you're black white
hispanic if you're on the right you're a
white supremacist and you're a Nazi that
has been made very clear
and the reason why they do that
is one obviously to try to discredit
everything we say without having to
engage with it
but two it is to set the stage for
violence
this this action for all of their talk
about inciting violence
when you go around claiming
that your political opponents are
literal Nazis
you are inciting violence against them
that's what you're doing
and you're doing it on purpose
that's the intention behind it obviously
all right let's see what else we have
here
this is a report from the daily wire it
says Sandy Hook families are asking a
Connecticut judge to order Alex Jones to
pay them trillions
trillions of dollars in Damages in
addition to the 965 million the jurors
ordered Jones to pay uh the families
the families claim that they are
entitled to the money because they
allege that Jones broke a state law that
bans the sale of goods through the use
of false statements
Bloomberg News reported that the
families arrived at 2.75 trillion
dollars by taking the maximum penalty
allowed under state law five thousand
dollars and multiplying it by 550
million social media views that Jones
got on social media accounts in the
three years following the 22 the 2012
shooting
the family's lawyer said Alex Jones
perpetrates this attack for one reason
greed Alex Jones will never treat them
like real people because they're too
valuable to him as targets so 2.75
trillion
this is obviously
grotesque and absurd it's a joke not a
funny joke but a joke
trillions of dollars
and I I say this as someone who from the
beginning I was extremely vocally
opposed to the Sandy Hook conspiracy
theories the idea that it was staged or
hoax or whatever never made any sense
there was never any good evidence to
support it
um there was never yet ever there was
never any evidence at all actually good
or not so you don't have to explain any
of that to me
even so what they're doing to Alex Jones
here
goes way way way beyond the Sandy Hook
stuff this is transparently an effort to
destroy him because he's Alex Jones
because he said a whole lot of other
things that are even more offensive to
the powers that be
that's obviously the case
no matter how you feel about Alex Jones
that's obviously the case and we know
it's the case we know it because if he
was really being bankrupted
and uh to the tune now of they're hoping
trillions of dollars
of course he doesn't have anything close
to trillion to trillions of dollars
nobody on Earth does not even Elon Musk
does
but um if it was really about
misinformation or defamation if we if we
lived in a country
where misinforming your audience or
defaming someone
actually led to you being utterly
financially ruined and you end up in the
whole by by uh 2.75 trillion dollars
then CNN would be ruined and MSNBC would
be ruined and the New York Times will be
ruined and the Associated Press will be
running CBS News we wrote Etc et cetera
Etc all of these institutions would be
held accountable to the same extent in
fact to a much greater extent if we were
the kind of country that treated
misinformation that harshly
a country really had no tolerance for it
at all
I mean all the atlas just mentioned
along with every other major corporate
media Outlet
have deliberately lied over and over
again
to feed
many false narratives including a racial
narrative that has led to city blocks
being burned and people actually dying
lots of people let's start with that far
from the only example but we could start
there
and that's not just misinformation
either it's also defamation
how many cops have been defamed lied
about
had their lives totally destroyed their
family's lives destroyed
how many left-wing media personalities
had to pay a billion dollars to officer
Darren Wilson for repeatedly claiming
that he shot an unarmed kid while his
hands were in the air begging you know
begging for mercy
how many billion dollar judgments were
meted out there
where's officer Darren Wilson now we've
seen him at all we haven't seen him he's
in hiding for the rest of his life his
life is ruined
because he's shot and killed someone who
was trying to kill him he shot he was a
a
totally justified shooting
which even which on the local and
federal level they found was justified
even Obama's the Obama Obama's doj tried
to find a reason to file hate crime
charges against him they looked at the
ballistics they looked at the evidence
and even they couldn't find it
doesn't matter this man's life is is
over his family's life is over
I mean hiding for the rest of his life
any billion dollar judgments for that
I mean there's that uh that that
Infamous now Infamous photo from I think
it was CNN
and all of the CNN reporters and anchors
are sitting around the table and they've
got their hands up and they're doing the
hands up don't shoot thing every single
one of them that's every single one of
them
misinformation defamation ruining
somebody's life
no accountability not one left-wing
media personality or Outlet was held
accountable for that or for pretty much
anything else
possible exception would be the the
misinformation the defamation connected
to the the um
uh the the Nicholas Sandman case
but even there you know we don't know
what the what the judgments so he won
some of those lawsuits thank God we
don't know what the judgments were but I
I think we can assume that it wasn't
billions
and I think it's pretty good chance
chance it wasn't even Millions
so when you when you look at the
contrast
right when you look at the people who
can get away with misinformation and
defamation
and the people who can't
um
it's very clear what the political
agenda is and there's just no there's
just no denying it
all right
you know we also have this clip which I
think we're gonna have to say for
tomorrow unfortunately
um it's a very it's a it's a weird thing
I started hearing from people yesterday
or a couple days ago that I appeared in
a Hallmark film
uh very much
without my knowing I was I made an
appearance in a Hallmark film it's a
film called Noel next door because
Hallmark there now uh they started doing
their 90 days of Christmas thing or
whatever it is where they start playing
a bunch of original and originally
terrible uniquely terrible Christmas
films in the lead up to Christmas and we
know the Hallmark has long since gone
woke
and so apparently they uh they had a a
character that that some viewers
figured seemed to be based on me and it
was kind of like a caricature of me and
I wanted to go through that clip and
watch it and just so see if we could
determined is this supposed to be me or
not but I think we have to save that for
tomorrow so tune in for that tomorrow
because we have to get now to our
comment section
they're the sweet baby gang
Scott slingerland says I think it's a
little unfair to talk about Corey Bush's
poor Book Sales she did quite well when
you consider how few of her loyal
followers are actually literate
there's a good point
that's a good point uh she probably sold
more books than she has literate fans
or fans at all so I could see that but
that's not that's no excuse I mean I
sold the book that was
intended for an audience of mostly
illiterate people and Johnny The Walrus
it was a kid's book you know it was a
kids book for for young kids many of
whom can't read and that book did
if I have to remind you again
extraordinarily well because I am if you
hadn't heard me mention it before in the
past now a best-selling LGBT children's
author Marco cures says my family and I
drove 500 miles to be at Friday's rally
I'm happy to report that after the event
though Satan is regrouped in a nearby
park and cried their eyes out and
consoled each other after the trauma of
seeing you live in person they know they
lost uh and did you get video of this
that's uh that is my question is there a
video so they were in a parking lot
crying after the event uh I would love
to see video of that
you know only so that I can extend my
sympathies to them
Lenny says Matt what do you think of
politicians trying to dodge debates
fetterman will debate Oz tonight but he
had to basically be forced into it
yeah I mean well for him it makes sense
I guess some fetterman and Oz are going
to debate tonight and it's it's going to
be a bloodbath it just is uh and it
would have been even before fetterman
lost his ability to speak coherent
sentences if he ever even really had
that ability to begin with but Oz is has
been on television for say whatever else
you want about him he's got a lot of
experience on TV and so he's been in
this kind of environment many many times
fetterman never has
so it's already a mismatch and then you
add on to it the fact that the
excitement legitimately has brain damage
and so uh yeah it's uh I'm not sure how
that's going to work at all so I don't I
actually don't I think that the debate
should happen I want the debates to
happen but it's politics and if you can
if you're in fetterman spot and you can
get away with not doing the debate of
course you will it would be political
malpractice to do a debate if you if
there was any way of getting out of it
but there was no way so you had to do at
least one that's what's happening
tonight uh it's also it's an interesting
strategy too by the way to to for him
he's doing one debate and he's doing it
so close to the election you'd think
maybe if you're gonna do only one uh
maybe schedule it for like a month ago
so when it goes horribly then you've got
time to try to change the subject
um or another way of looking at it is do
it very close to the election so that if
it goes horribly there's not a lot of
time for that damage to there's not a
lot of time for all the clips and videos
of you choking to circulate I don't know
maybe that's the strategy they're going
with
um
Jack says I've always avoided getting
involved in activism because all the
ones I've ever met
have been really self-righteous and
annoying but to be fair they were all
activists for leftist causes this is
something I can get behind it's needed
and it's time to save children I'm on
board well I'm glad to hear that you're
on board and uh
what you're saying is exactly what we
talked about yesterday this is the you
know why the right doesn't get involved
in activism as much they have this
notion of it as this like silly thing
and and uh you know
uh and we're we're suffering the
consequences of that we're suffering the
consequences of thinking that we're you
know we don't have time to be activists
and we're we've got jobs and everything
else and so we can't do it and it's true
we do have jobs and that is another
disadvantage because we don't you know
we've got to take off work if you want
to go to a rally or protest in the
middle of the day but do we want to save
the country or not you know are we just
going to give up and activism it's not
the be-all and end-all but there cannot
be any political or cultural strategy
that doesn't include any activism at all
it does have an impact it does matter
it's why the left does it
um
Mi prepper says I've uh I guess that's
Michigan pepper I've been a moderate
I've been a moderate voting for both
Democrats and Republicans my whole life
this year I'm voting straight Republican
for the first time uh it's going to be a
straight ticket I'm hearing a lot of
that kind of thing which leads again to
the coming Red Wave I would think and uh
Jonathan says Matt as a Muslim I support
you and believe in your intentions I
think everyone in the DW is working on
what all of our faiths preach and that
is why Muslims like you and Jordan
Peterson and secretly Ben Shapiro
yeah there is uh as I said yesterday
if you're a religious person and I have
to always stipulate a
an adherent to an old religion the
leftism itself is a religions I don't
mean that
um if you are a religious person in the
other sense of the word
then you would think that there would be
plenty of grounds for
um in Alliance when it comes to these
cultural issues
and I think that there is Jill says Matt
you've been chiming in on airplane
controversies but you haven't mentioned
the biggest one window shade up or down
please tell me you have the correct view
which is that it always stays down I
think we have talked about this before
and unfortunately
that means that your band Jill twice
over you're banned once for not being
able to recall every single thing we've
talked about which tells me that you're
not taking notes during the show which
is unacceptable and you're banned again
for uh having the absolutely deranged
and defensible position that the window
shade should stay down
so I'm just going to say a few things to
reiterate first of all I am a frequent
flyer uh I'm probably in the top
I don't know one percent in terms of the
amount of time spent flying in a given
year
and and yet and yet even I in plans all
the time I can still appreciate the fact
that every time we fly we are getting
access to A View to a a physical
perspective that nearly all human beings
on Earth who've ever lived have never
had access to thousands of generations
came and went without without any one of
them ever seeing the Earth from more
than a few hundred feet up and most of
them there was never more than like
eight or nine feet up in there if that
and we're able to see from 35 000 feet
and you want to keep the shade down
we have this view of the earth that no
almost no one's ever been able to see
and you want to you don't you didn't
want to look at it
do you go to the Grand Canyon or just
keep your back turned to it the entire
time
you probably do because that's what
people do now they give their back turns
they can take selfies so they experience
the Grand Canyon through the phone
behind them
and they fall off and die it happens
every day
second
you are not the only one in your road
Jill just because you're closest to the
window does not mean that you own the
window you don't pay for the window you
pay for the seat just like if you sit
near the wing of the plane you don't own
the wing if you sit closest to the
engine you don't own the engine you
don't you don't own the window you don't
own that part of the plane it's just
it's your it's the seat that you paid
for not the window okay we all paid for
access to the row we share the row you
have your own seat
the window belongs to the road so if you
want to put that window shade down you
need to get permission from the other
people in the row
um third and final point
I need to be able to see out of the
window
so that I can keep the plane in the sky
with my brain waves
that is science all right I can't
explain it it's just I feel like the
plane's more likely to crash if I can't
look out the window
it's it's literally science it is a
scientific fact that if I can see out
the window the plane is less likely to
crack crash
it's been tested by scientists who were
doing science and they determine this
Media Matters can quote me on this I
want this to be the next reason that I
am trending on Twitter Matt Walsh says
that he keeps planes in the sky with his
brain waves I am actually saying that
right now
make that Trend do it the whole world
needs to see and know about this
well now feels like a good time to read
another email the daily wire was cc'd on
in an ongoing ad segment called breakup
letters no these are not Tom Brady and
Gisele's hacked emails but real messages
from former Harris razer's customers who
cancel their subscriptions and switch to
Jeremy's today's letter is from a man
writing to Harry's quote I've been a
subscriber since 2015 but I'm canceling
because I'm one of the knuckle dragging
Savages that believes in traditional
morality I stuck with you all after the
Gillette razor snafu but I'm leaving
because of your treatment of daily wire
delete my account
well said when it comes to all these
woke virtue signaling companies delete
my account is the new lose my number and
frankly the only acceptable response to
a partner who hates you so if you're a
man who also Believes In traditional
masculine values like not wearing a
dress or ritualistically declaring that
boys can be girls and girls can be boys
it's past time that you ditch your woke
razor and pick up a Jeremy's razor
instead go right now to
jeremy'srazors.com get 40 off your
Founders a shave kit today that's
jeremy'srazors.com stop giving your
money to woke corporations give it to
Jeremy instead and keep the breakup
emails coming by copying us at reviews
at jammiesraisers.com now let's get to
our daily cancellation
foreign
right after Will Smith assaulted Chris
Rock on stage at the Oscars at the best
of his emotionally abusive wife Legions
of apologists on social media came up
with a brilliant excuse in the form of a
what about him
they declared that criticism of Smith
and his eventual banishment from the
academy
was hypocritical was even racist because
John Wayne assaulted a Native American
woman on stage at the Oscars and never
faced any backlash now that claim dates
back to 1973 when a woman named sasheen
littlefeather took the stage in her buck
skin dress and Indian get up to uh turn
down the Oscar on behalf of Marlon
Brando she explained that Brando
couldn't accept the award for his
performance in The Godfather because of
a long list of grievances having to do
with Hollywood's treatment of Native
Americans uh the complaints went beyond
Hollywood actually went all the way back
to Wounded Knee in 1890. now why a
massacre in South Dakota in the 19th
century would prevent Marlon Brando from
accepting an Oscar in Hollywood in the
20th century was never explained the
greater Point as far as the social media
peanut gallery was concerned
is that John Wayne was never held
accountable for his vicious assault of
the Native American Woman
of course John Wayne didn't assault
anyone on stage a story which grows with
each retelling much like the eight pound
bass I caught last June which was a five
and a half pound bass as recently as
last month is that John Wayne had to be
held back by security because he tried
to rush the stage and assault the woman
like that that was that was that's the
story it was now they say it was assault
before it was he was trying to rush the
stage turns out that the story about him
trying to Russian stage is also an
exaggeration of the original story which
was that John Wayne was fuming backstage
and ranting about how he wanted to go up
there and pull her off the stage but
then he never did and yet that story too
as far as we could tell was also made up
there's no evidence that John Wayne did
anything of note that night
nothing actually happened this is an
urban legend that started to gain steam
back in the 70s and has taken on a new
life in recent years whenever the racial
grievance Peddlers can make use of it
but
the story it turns out is even Faker
than we thought
not only did John Wayne never try to
assault the Native American Woman
but evidently there never was any Native
American woman to assault in the first
place
as a report in the San Francisco
Chronicle reveals this week only only a
few weeks after her death
sasheen littlefeather
who died earlier in the month
um and had become a prominent Native
American activist after that incident at
the Oscars spoke out about Native
American issues for decades
was not actually Native American
the chronicle reports quote according to
her biological sisters Rosalind Cruz and
Trudy Orlandi littlefeather isn't native
at all it's a lie Orlando told me in an
exclusive interview my father who was uh
was was who he was his family came from
Mexico and uh my dad was born in Oxford
it is a fraud Cruz agreed it's
disgusting to the heritage of the tribal
people and it's just insulting to my
parents
Little Feather sisters both said in
separate interviews that they have no
known Native American slash American
Indian ancestry they identified as
Spanish on their father's side and
insisted their family had no claims to a
tribal identity
quote I mean you're not going to be a
Mexican-American princess or Landy said
of her sister's adoption of a fraudulent
identity you're going to be an American
Indian princess it was more prestigious
to be an American Indian than it was to
be Hispanic in her mind
so this news has been devastating to
those who championed her as an activist
for All Those Years yet it's a great
relief to Elizabeth Warren who is
practically an Apache warrior in
comparison to this woman at least Warren
is one one set one thousandth Native
American or whatever it was Little
Feather whose real name was Marie Louise
Cruz didn't even have that much
uh claim the article goes on to provide
a possible reason why Crews decided to
play dress-up quote news coverage of her
burgeoning attempts to make a name for
herself in the entertainment World hint
at a possible reason for assuming a
native identity about four months before
Little Feather appeared at the Oscars on
September 28 1972 legendary Chronicle
columnist herb Kane wrote a piece about
a turn for the worse in her modeling
career quote sashing littlefeather the
Bay Area Indian princess and nine other
tribal Beauties are soar at Hugh Hefner
Playboy ordered pictures of them riding
horseback nude in Woodside and other
Beauty spots and then Hefner rejected
the shots as not erotic enough
um why do them in the first place well
explain Little Feather everybody says
black is beautiful we want it to show
that red is two like many aspiring
actors this was assuredly not how Little
feather's Dream of stardom was supposed
to go but perhaps it was better than
being ignored
better than being ignored Billy sums it
up doesn't it it should come as no
surprise that even back in the 70s
professional victimhood was already
becoming a lucrative career
I mean that is the decade after all when
the Boomers came of age and they are the
ones who invented the field of of the
professional victimhood they created
this industry and the Marcus Marketplace
that demands it
and it's also it also comes as no
surprise that neither this San Francisco
Chronicle article nor any other article
or commentary in the corporate media
about this fraud actually grapples with
the fundamental question here
and that question is
why is victimhood so profitable why is
it desirable in our culture to be a
victim
how is it that people can establish long
and distinguished careers for themselves
as professional victims
the chronicle comes up with an
individual explanation for Cruz she was
failing as an actress and as a model and
looking for another way to get attention
but they don't widen the lens and look
at the bigger picture because they never
do because they know that if they did
they would see what they do not want to
see namely that the desire for
victimhood is a culture-wide disease
Sashi littlefeather and Elizabeth Warren
and Rachel dollazal and all the rest of
them the many many many rest of them
didn't come up with this on their own or
in a vacuum it is a societal phenomenon
we are conditioning people to desire
control and power for its own sake and
to attain it in the most shameful
passive aggressive manipulative way
possible
through emotional blackmail and the
exploitation of misplaced sympathies
now of course people in all cultures in
all periods of history have desired
power and control that's part of the
human condition
but there are good and bad reasons for
wanting it and there are good and bad
ways to try and obtain it
in times past whether power was desired
for a good or bad reason
most often the way to achieve it
was through Success Through uh greatness
through achievement
if you wanted to be somebody you had to
do something you had to accomplish
something
now we've created a society where a lack
of accomplishment is an accomplishment
the less you do the more you can claim
you are oppressed
you just need to belong to the right
demographics
and if you don't well that's an easy fix
you can just lie lie about it
that's what the character known as Sashi
littlefeather figured out and many young
people today are discovering the same
thing
and so as it is probably redundant at
this point to cancel a woman who just
died instead I think today we will again
say to all victimhood Merchants that you
are canceled that'll do it for the show
today
um talk to you tomorrow have a great day
Godspeed
[Music]
John Bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less join me and
my co-host Georgia Howe for daily
coverage of all the biggest stories on
morning wire
[Music]